it's time for battle of the bite size
screaming
and we're lucky enough to do it with
jesse and julie
and me and of course rossi ross matthew
hi
[Applause]
we're guys excited to do this with you
guys look at what a motley crew i'm so
excited
okay well the winning ice cream shop
gets the cherry on top and the claims of
the majestic battle of the bites trophy
it's rocking the ice cream today wow
let's get into it first up is sugar hill
creamery from
harlem new york take a look
i'm patricia bazen-larson this is nick
larson
we're the co-founders and co-owners of
sugar hill creamery sugar hill creamery
is
a family owned ice cream shop that
serves small batch ice cream made by
our resident ice cream maker we strongly
believe in using raw ingredients
and using good ingredients to create our
ice creams the flavors are informed by
our caribbean and midwestern cultures
we are inspired by our family heritage
as we
create flavors that we share with other
families
and harlem residents yay
i love it um jesse and julie a man and a
woman
teaming up to make fantastic
food and ingredients all right here we
go look at me i'm ready you go
i'm ready this first one has
butterscotch in it yeah and like a
little
heath bar kind of taste too
like the inside of a heath bar um
really good it's like if you put a dark
chocolate bar in the freezer
the vanilla was quite interesting jesse
the vanilla is definitely my favorite of
this this batch here wow that was
delicious holy cow wow
that was utterly hilarious
all right let's go to our next dreamy
business
up next we have ice cream jubilee from
washington d.c
let's take a look i'm victoria lai
i'm the founder and chief ice cream
preneur of ice cream jubilee here in our
nation's capital
washington dc i became a government
lawyer here in dc
but soon after i realized that i was
missing the colors and the flavors and
the excitement and the joy
that comes with sharing ice cream so in
my own apartment i started mixing up
flavors and taking inspiration for
anywhere i could find it
i was living a life full of colors and
flavors and it was
my dream i hope you enjoy our ice cream
and try more flavors at ice cream
jubilee.com
i love her story she was like a
washington dc lawyer and was like
i'm not happy i want to go make ice
cream
that's the definition of a pivot
absolutely and yet it's such a good
example to us
all to find our dream in this sort of
life is short but beautiful scenario
okay here we go ice cream jubilee
i'm starting with the cherries jubilee
because you know
okay oh my god
okay okay that's so good
i'm not getting cherries as much as yes
i taste more
bananas um but it's beautiful
drew could you take a trip to that top
scoop it's the banana
um bourbon one wait maybe i am eating
the banana burger
that might explain a few things i'm like
i'm not really getting cherries
i'm kidding jesse
uh julie which one are you guys eating
and liking
i'm gonna say i love any cherry dessert
this cherry ice cream i like that the
cherries subtle it's almost like a mint
chip
like the the flecks of uh chocolate in
there
this is slamming well what's crazy about
what she's done
is in the cookies and cream the cookie
is
fluffy how did it not get like dense wet
and
like smooshed it's like it's fluffy
i don't really get it it's confusing and
amazing
but
don't sleep on that banana though i
can't stop digging in on that
it's i i really i'm with julie i really
loved the cherry as well okay
finally we have made our way south with
lick
honest ice screams from austin texas
take a lick and i mean take a look
hey drew and friends i'm chad and i'm
anthony and we are the co-founders of
like honest ice creams in austin texas
we make what we call honest ice creams
and for us that means knowing where
every ingredient comes from using super
clean
ingredients and that starts with our
milk and cream which come from
a local family-owned dairy about an hour
and a half from our production kitchen
we have scoop shops and awesome in san
antonio if you can't make it here
get on gold belly we ship across the
country thanks for having us hope you
enjoyed
thank you all right guys
well they couldn't be cute are those two
i was thinking the same
thing alrighty then um
uh coffee whipped cream
um jesse there's a hill country honey
and vanilla bean
just for you he's obsessed with all
these vanilla flavors and they're all so
different
it's crazy that there's there's such a
difference between the sugar hill one
and the lick one
right and then the last is texas
sheet cake sheet cake is one of the
first desserts i ever made
i love love love texas cheat cake so
i'm a fan of this ice cream too my
favorite from the lick honest ice creams
is um the coffee the coffee i'm just
gonna say the coffee
are you guys ready the moment has come
are we ready to vote
yes this is hard i know it
is hard all right um that said um the
time has come
one at a time we're gonna reveal our
favorites
all right um all i'll jump in
and again just do it i'm gonna go sugar
hill creamery
okay ross um
all right i'm voting with you
oh julie it's your turn
you know i gotta go with jubilee
because it was
really really good okay jesse what have
you got
someone's gonna have to make an extra
trophy because that's a tie
oh my gosh okay so guess what
we get a two for both ice cream shops
they're each getting a trophy
[Applause]
that makes me so happy and to get the
scoop on some of our favorite ice cream
shops around the country
excuse me
i think i just became lactose intolerant
this second
get the scoop on some of our favorite
ice cream shops from around the country
visit our website
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
and this is the cookbook you cannot live
without
jesse tyler ferguson and julie tannis
food
between friends is available now
wherever books are sold
get it while it's hot